des masques des coussins des sacs et cet
atelier textile emploie une vingtaine de
salariés en insertion à conflans sainte
honorine
il travaille pour et qualys une
association on a des accompagnements qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à deux ans on règle
générale sur un chantier
la règle commune à nos chantiers c'est
plutôt un an après un parcours chez nous
en moyenne c'est un an avec beaucoup
d'accompagnement vers les formations les
formations qu'on espère plutôt
qualifiante pour eux et sinon c'est
aussi des emplois très diversifiée dans
le domaine de la vente du service à la
personne et qualys géré hui chantier
d'insertion dont deux à conflans sainte
honorine les jardins de cocaïne sont
spécialisés dans le maraîchage bio une
activité accompagné par l' agence
départementale activity présente depuis
cinq ans on a la capacité pas seulement
d'accompagner en fonctionnement mais on
a mis des moyens de l'investissement
pourquoi je vous dis c'est original
parce que dans l'insertion dans l'action
sociale par nature on est souvent dans
le fonctionnement pas dans
l'investissement
or ces structures lorsqu'elle se lance
sur des nouveaux défis sont des nouveaux
projets elles ont besoin d' le coup de
pouce de départ de l'investissement et
c'est se comporter en arrière on
l'apporté plusieurs années de suite et
un projet d'investissement ces cinquante
mille euros par an implanté dans les
yvelines depuis 1978 et qualys est
présente dans neuf départements
franciliens dans l'oise et le loiret
elle accompagne 200 salariés en
insertion